Vincent is with us in Washington DC hive
incent welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave how you doing better than I
deserve sir how can I help you today
that's real quick they have on 20 years
old I'm about to be a first-time dad to
swing boys Double Trouble how old you
say I'm 28 28 awesome man
proud for you congratulations how come
I've been calling you now for about over
a year and thanks to you last year alone
I paid off about $40,000 worth of debt
only thing left on my debt is my wife's
car loan which is separate than mine and
my mortgage when I found out we were
expecting
I see Neil II started I stopped paying
extra on these loans and I start
stacking money as fast do it you knew
when I like to hold off on paying to set
off early today for money pay for
medical related expenses I'm worried I'm
not doing enough
no you just stop you're exactly right
you stop everything push pause and you
pile up cash as high as you can pile it
now have you got good health insurance
to take care of her in the babies I do
sir to my place okay good good what's
your deductible
I believe it's five dollar deductible
$500 Wow okay so you've got full
coverage very expensive benefits are
very expensive and and what's your copay
past that 8020 I believe it's 20 okay
all right cool well twins have a higher
probability of coming early and so
there's a higher probability of some
minor things nothing to be afraid about
but it's just a more exciting pregnancy
and delivery and you know there's more
things that can happen and so twice as
much as a matter of fact but you know
some bed rest and some things like that
can happen late in the pregnancy
obviously because she's carrying twice
as much baby and that kind of thing so
um you know I'm just
pile up cash as high as I can pilot and
I'm gonna just watch this wonderful
nine-month process unfold perfect so far
$15,000 won't hurt at all won't hurt at
all cuz let's let's predict that
absolutely nothing occurs outside of an
ordinary labor and delivery okay and
then you're gonna be five hundred
dollars out of pocket plus twenty
percent of ten thousand so about another
two grand I'm gonna throw that number
around okay so you're gonna need about
twenty five hundred to the twenty
thousand to pay your medical bills when
it comes you built up twenty two
thousand five hundred by then you're
gonna take the other twenty thousand and
throw it right straight at your debt how
much debt have you got left only left
about twenty thousand dollars on my
wife's car and on our home loan we only
had to posit two hundred eighty thousand
your home loan is baby step six we're
not dealing with that today at all okay
and so when Mommy and bet and boys come
home and everybody's healthy and you
know we just go touchdown this is over
okay it's settled back in then we're
gonna take the twenty thousand bucks and
throw and pay off her car cool but and
so what did you lose if you pile up
twenty thousand dollars instead of
paying down the car during this nine
months you lost the interest on twenty
thousand dollars for nine months yes and
she went it hasn't got this car without
even talking to me man this is before
you were married yeah not at sixteen
percent
holy crying well that's good yeah I've
already gonna cost you a couple grand
then two to sit on the money I'm still
gonna sit on the money because I'm more
concerned with babies and mommies than I
am debt free cars because we're get
around to the debt free car it's just
gonna be a little while before you get
there like nine months worth at this
stage of the game eight months or
whenever you went public with this six
months five months wherever we got left
okay but just wonderful time meant I'll
just tell you this a big old pile of
cash lowers the stress level a lowered
stress level helps the pregnancy just
basic grandpa stuff right there man
that's not a medical and that's not a
medical opinion so hey man thanks for
the call